what they can expect from hot summer
nights well you know hopefully an
authentic coming-of-age story you know
hopefully a truthful portrayal of what
it's like to be a teenager and it come
to two terms of feelings of of romance
and and maturity and adulthood for the
first time so and can you briefly
describe all right so I played Daniel
Middleton in one word no no no I one
word teenager teenager how would I
describe my character word sentence I
think you know sexy characters are very
well they're all very complex so like
it's hard to explain briefly but um you
guys are all getting along as people as
friends as colleagues but dynamic the
chemistry on set
no even great you know even lived in a
we all lived in a house together while
we were shooting in and actually the
teenager heart thing all the things I
just said that was our producer Ryan
freaking he threw that on a press notes
thing you know he's 25 years old - and
Elijah's 28 our director so there's a
bunch of young people you know they're
all it was a great experience you know
so yeah let's talk about this new
Hollywood up-and-coming young you know
talent that were
more and more of these days and where do
you find your confidence from where you
find your comfort level from can you
expand gosh
I mean it's um it's a very hard industry
and and I think you have to have a tough
skin and be ok with being told no a
million times and and and I don't know
it's there's really high-ups and really
low lows and and you just kind of have
to be confident within yourself and and
yeah I think the biggest thing is like
not identifying your work with like your
lifestyle and if you can like really
make that difference and that separation
then you don't feel like your life is
being ruled by it so like when you're
told no it doesn't like seep into your
personal life and you don't like become
like to work on a script that was as
cool as this one so I think yeah chasing
really like good projects like this and
like not taking no for an answer I think
it's the thing that helps ask you who of
the group then is the rebel who is the
most romantic who is the troublemaker
say Elijah you know Elijah lives just
the rebel you know at 28 years old he
wrote an incredible script that was a
throwback to a time that yeah I didn't
actually live in you know it was 1992 he
was one years old as he said in other
interviews so he's the rebel on the
bunch and he's the one you know he's the
one that put this all together so Elijah
wasn't it part of the question you got
it's you for I don't know I mean
very um rebel but not even not really
Emory Emory Cowan oh he was the
troublemaker he got us all in trouble
actually he really got us going
Emory we're gonna blame this one on
Emory so you were single you all put
into a place together what city were you
in how did it how did that we shot in
Atlanta yeah yeah it was awesome I
haven't done a lot of films I've done a
decent amount and and there was
something very special about this group
we had we had a we had a chemistry read
but that was the first time I met
actually out tonight work together sorry
I was like no I don't know anyone Alex
and I have worked together before but um
no it's it's a special it's a special
group to take a while to get them no no
I mean I came late onto the project and
I met them on my first day I think
shooting I had just met Alex when we had
our first scene so if there wasn't
really time to like do that it's like
you just thrown into it and you just
like but it was easy with these guys so
which case I think because it was such a
young like it was a young director young
producer we were all kind of like it was
easy for us to go get on together there
was no kind of formalities it was just
straight and to just being ourselves and
kind of like everything Alex said I
disagree with totally his no I agree
with totally no no no I know I know it's
just just but to that point add onto he
knows all we were all young there wasn't
a generational gap that you can feel in
other film sets you know there was a
certain relatability amongst everyone
because like I like said Ryan and Elijah
were 2025 years old so everyone
everyone's kind of going through a
similar process